so good afternoon everybody thank you so
much for coming this is the last session
of all of the back-to-backs after
yesterday's
interesting experience so thank you so
much for coming to join me here
now I'm going to be talking about static
web apps and Blazer today and it all
started
sometime mid-2021 and I saw this blog
post that was talking about building
your own brand
that if you are blogging on somebody
else's platform no matter how awesome
that platform is you're putting your
time your effort and your energy
into building up somebody else's brand
rather than doing your own
I thought wow
it's kind of a point
and I literally embed at quarter past 10
at night brought a domain
actually I've got three domains because
seriously who can ever buy one and I got
Stacey clouds.com Stacey clouds.net and
Stacey clouds.dev
and after that
I did nothing because buying a domain
and using a domain are two separate
Hobbies
and the thing that stopped me was
I didn't just want to put a static text
blog out there I wanted to try new
things experiment learn new stuff and
that meant that I needed a web server
and I needed to get the DNS sorted and I
have a full-time job and a family and a
Lego addiction and there was just no way
that I had time to do this
and I started to learn about Blazer and
it's okay I can make a quick web
application that's cool but I've still
got to host it
and then I started to play with Azure
static web apps and I've been playing
with them since they were in preview
and
I love them instantly and I love them
instantly because all of the stuff that
I didn't actually want to care about and
I did actually want to learn about at
that time I didn't need to
if I build a webassembly application I
can deploy that as a static site I don't
need to worry about servers I don't need
to worry about setting anything up I
don't need to worry about paying for an
app service plan if I'm doing it inside
of azure it's all done for me
and to get the dynamic data that I want
I've got Azure functions and I can get
the data out there
and even better than that if you do this
in
say you're using a storage account and a
static web app inside of a storage
account you can hook that up to
functions too then you have to worry
about cores and then you have to get
your domains working properly and you
need to proxy it a little bit to get it
to work nicely and it was awesome
but it's a pain very quickly you get up
to like five different resources that
you've got to contain
with a static web apps it's one and in
that one container we have our static
front end we have our Azure back end and
we have all this lovely glue which joins
the two together and makes one usable
application that I don't have to worry
about because I love not having to worry
about how to wire all of this up
and so I started to build my website and
it was kind of a work in progress it
will be for an age yet
but just something that I could fire up
in an evening when I didn't have
anything to do haha
and
put an hour or two hours and just take
it one step further one step further and
learn as I went
and yeah I've now got something that's
kind of online it's kind of looking past
decent and it does what I want it to do
it takes my blog post from dev.2 and it
displays them on my website in my look
and feel and the next step is to add
authentication and move forward
and what I want to do today is actually
go through that with you to create a
static web app to get it deployed to
implement authentication to look at
debugging to make a custom domain and
just to see what we can do really
quickly to get something working tell
the world who you are
which is a nice segue who am I hi I'm
Stacey Cashmore I am Tech Explorer
devops at omniplan we are a financial
advice software company based in
Amsterdam in the Netherlands I've been
coding since the mid 1990s and I am
supremely honored to say that I've been
a Microsoft MVP for the last two years
now enough of me talking let's have a
look at some code and see how many typos
I can do in the next 40 50 minutes
so the first thing that we're going to
be doing today is actually just
basically making our application and
we're going to do that by just firing up
our Blazer webassembly app and an Azure
function
so let's get that going let's see if I
can actually see the screen on the side
of me
there we go we want a Blazer webassembly
app
uh we're going to be calling it client
we are going to put putting it in that
location because I need that for my
GitHub repo to work
and we also need to give it a name to
get the GitHub repo to work too
so let's just bring that one across
there we go and
I press back instead of forward didn't I
oh good it remembered everything
there we go we want a net six long-term
Support app because of course we do and
we're not going to be worrying about
authentication at this stage I'm going
to be adding that later on we're going
to be configuring it for https because
please always configure it for https
we're not going to be hosting it in
a.net core application because of course
we want those static files that we can
deploy and I'm doing nothing with pwa so
we're just going to ignore that box for
now
let's create that and get that one spun
up
thought nice little computer
come on you can do it you're not
connected to teams you can be faster
than this
and into this solution we are going to
add a new project and that new project
is going to be our Azure functions how
we're going to get data uh to our front
end
we're going to be calling this one API
and you may notice I called the Blazer
client and I'm calling this API there is
a reason for that and I'll get to that
in about five minutes
we want that in the same place let's
bring it in
and we're going to make this empty so
that I don't have to just delete
everything as soon as I create it
so this is going to be the core of our
application now the first thing we're
going to do I don't need to delete
anything from the API because that has a
nice empty template I am going to delete
an amount of stuff on the Blazer
application because I don't want all of
that example code in there
I remember mainly from Steve session
yesterday they are going to make an
empty template for Blazer so
hopefully I don't have to do this for
too much longer
so the first thing we're going to do
we're going to delete Jimmy's favorite
page the counter
and we're going to delete the fetch data
no not the whole page is directory that
would be bad
but we are going to delete the sample
data because I don't want to leave that
one in there either I really like this a
little bit clean and then because we
deleted those pages we're just going to
clean up the navigation a little bit too
so we're going to open this shared
folder open the nav menu and we're going
to delete these last two items
so anybody who's ever nude up a Blazer
project you will see on the sidebar you
have a counter link you have a fetch
data link and we don't have those
anymore
last but not least I want to clean up uh
the main layout just a little bit
so I want to get rid of this link to the
asp.net documentation
it's an awesome link use it if you need
it but I don't particularly want it on
my blog so we're going to take that out
and I think we're about saying let's get
rid of this survey prompt too so we
don't want that either
and then we do the wonderful first build
and what did I break
drum roll please
build please yes builds it seated cool
we can carry on then
so the first thing that I'm going to do
here is I'm going to read all of my blog
posts on dev.2 and I'm going to make
them available to put onto my website uh
I said I love dev.2 I still post to
dev.2 I just display it on my website
right now and when I switch that I'm
still going to cross post to dev.2
automatically because it is a nice
platform it's just not the only place I
want to be
so inside of our API we're going to make
a models folder because
I'm going to do some real demo coding
later on today but I'm going to start
off properly and not be too bad at the
beginning
so we want a model's directory and then
we're going to make
an object to hold our Dev doc two posts
so let's add a new class
and let's call that blog post summary
and like I say
you don't want to watch me do typos for
the next 45 minutes or maybe you do I
don't know in which case I apologize so
what I'm going to be doing is bringing
over a load of Snippets and I'm going to
be walking you through them as we build
them
so this first one it is just a model
class so we're just using the uh system
text Json serialization name space and
that's because
the object we get from dev.2 doesn't
quite fit the model that I want inside
of my application so I'm just doing a
couple of quick transformations
and we're going to get the ID of the
blog post we're going to get the title a
description the URL that we need to go
to to actually see the blog post and
we're going to get a publish date which
is actually for a different demo than we
have today but um yeah it's in that
we'll get it anyway
next thing we want to do is actually
make the function itself so let's add a
new Azure function here
you want to add an Azure function
we want that one called blog posts
and that one needs to be a HTTP trigger
because inside of an Azure static web
app you can only use HTTP trigger for
your Azure functions
unless they've changed it since the last
time I read it and in which case I'm
lying to you
so we're going to get rid of all of this
code because we're going to bring across
a pre-written function and what this is
going to do is
um
we're going to support the HTTP get
method we are going to be running on the
URL of blog post so that will be API
blog posts
and we are going to get a HTTP client I
will go through that one in a second
because the dev.2 the special stuff you
have to do
and basically what I'm going to do from
dev.2 is just go to their API you don't
need a key in order to do this it's open
to the world
and we're going to get all of the
articles for my username Stacy
underscore cash
we are going to deserialize those to an
innumerable of the blog post summary
and then we're going to send it back to
whoever's calling and that's all we need
our function to do here
the HTTP client I just want to mention
this because my blog post was down for
like a week
and it was down because they've got to
added two fields that you needed to put
into the headers
um one was the product value the other
was a comment value and I don't think it
actually matters what you put in here
but you need to put something in here or
they just give you a really bad response
and nothing works and you pull your hair
out a little bit
another quick build make sure I've not
done anything wrong yet
and then we can move on
to the fun stuff we can actually get it
displayed on the screen so let's close
all the pages so far
close all tabs that's good and we'll
drop the API so we're not quite as
confused
first thing we need to do
I still need that model that we just
used so that I can read the blog posts
in and use them on my site now before
somebody complains in the front row
I would not copy this code in my actual
website I would make a shared models
project for this so that I'm not
repeating all of this code but it's
quicker just to do this and make an
extra project on the fly so that's why
we're doing it this way
so for that we are going to add a new
folder here again
and that's going to be models
and inside of there we are going to make
another new object so add class
wait for the laptop
and this is kind of just really similar
to what we had before only I don't need
all of the Json attributes on this one
so it just looks a little bit uh cleaner
we just have again the ID URL title
description and publish date
next thing we're going to do is make a
service which is going to make that call
to the API from our Blazer application
so we're going to add another new folder
that one
and this one's going to be called
services and we're going to make a blog
post summary service and what this is
going to do is make the request of the
Azure function it is going to hold the
values that we get back so each time we
come to this component we're not having
to remake the same API call and do all
of that waiting on i o
to bring this one across
and for this we are injecting a HTTP
client and we get this out of the box
inside of a Blazer Solution that's
automatically uh in our dependency
injection container
we are making available a list of blog
post summaries that we can use outside
of the service
we have our Constructor taken in the
HTTP container client of course
and then we just have this load
summaries and what we're doing here is
just checking do I already have a
collection of summaries if I do fine
finish and if I don't we're going to
make that call out so that we can get it
so the first time we
um use it we have to wait and after that
it's just really Snappy
and the last thing I have to do is add
this service to my program CS so that I
can use it inside of my components
and we have a nice red squiggly line so
let's do Ctrl Dot
and bring in the using statement and
that should all build now
yes
last step for this section we're
actually going to put the blog posts on
the screen and for that we're going to
make a new page
so we're going to come into our Pages
folder and we are going to add no we're
not going to scope to this at all
come on get me home thank you
we are going to oh come on
sometimes mice can be really sensitive
we're going to add a razor component
we're not going to add a razor page
which confused me the first time I did
this we're going to add a razor
component the Razer pages are only for
the MVC I believe it creates a CS HTML
if you do it just delete it go back it's
fine
and we're going to call that blog posts
and then bring yet another snippet
so what do we have inside of here well
we have a using statement for our
client.services so that we can get
access to that new blog post service we
made and we have a page directive at the
top and this is what turns it into a
page Jimmy please correct me if I'm
wrong here all pages are components but
not all components are pages
thank you
we are injecting our blog post summary
service so that we can use it to display
our blog posts
um and then we actually get on to the
nice stuff for the users adding a page
title and a H1 that both say the same
thing but they do different things in
the background
page title sets your tab so that you can
see what site you're on and the H1 is
for the users on the page itself
we're checking to see whether or not the
service.summer is is null and if it is
then we know there's nothing there yet
so we're going to show a loading sign
and if we do have summaries then for
each one we're just going to put on the
page the title The publish that the
description and a link to the summary
URL which because I know it's a DOT
pattern but I don't want people to leave
my website yet I'm opening in a
different tab
last but not least a little code block
underneath which just on the
initialization of the component is going
to call that blog post summaries load
summaries so that we can actually get
our information from the back end
one last thing we need to do for this
first kickoff bit is give our users a
way to access our blog post page so for
that one we're going to come into our
navigation menu again where we just
deleted a load of stuff
and we are going to add a second link
and because I really hate it when
stuff's not aligned properly we're going
to tab it a little bit
and this is just going to put a link on
the side for blog posts and that is
going to link to our page that we've
just added
I know Bill did it work it worked this
is good
next thing is it going to work on life
so what we're going to do now we're not
going to run this locally yet
The Next Step we're actually going to
create our static web app and actually
get this application out onto the web so
we've added our app
we're going to push that out
to GitHub we're going to keep our
fingers crossed for the wiffy
come on you've started you can finish
yes
and then we can go online
so this is my repo that we've just been
using and you can see it's fairly empty
aside from the good ignore and if I
refresh this now we should hopefully see
an API a client and our solution
so we're going to put this out on the
web now
I already have a resource Group set up
for my static web apps so inside of
there we're just going to create a new
resource
and that's going to be
a static web app
so let's create this one
and I'm going to check the subscription
and Resource Group is the same this
should always be correct and in theory
it is but the difference between Theory
and practices and Theory the same and in
practice they're not and there are a few
resources in Azure that have a bug and
they leave the resource Group empty and
it will create a new one for you
automatically and suddenly you've got no
idea where your things are living so
always check this
then we need to give it a name and for
this one we're going to call it our NDC
London the nice one here is if you
create an app service plan in Azure you
have to have a name which is unique to
the whole of azure
for static web apps you don't because
this doesn't influence your url as yours
going to make you a URL so as long as
this is unique inside of your resource
Group it's fine it hopefully makes
naming a little bit simpler although it
does make the URLs a lot more
interesting
then we have the plan that we want we
have a free tier which does quite a lot
of stuff and then we have a standard
tier that just adds a little bit of
Enterprise goodness on top
um further price wise that standard app
is still only about
seven I'm from Holland it's seven euros
a month I'm sorry I have no idea what
that is in pounds
um but it's not an expensive resource to
use and it gives you access to private
endpoints to custom authentication and a
load of other things which will
hopefully get to later on in this talk
for now though we're going to leave it
free we're going to use just what's out
of the box and see what we can do
we're going to put it in a region and
like say I'm from the Netherlands so I'm
going to pick West Europe
and then we see where we're deploying
from now I find it interesting that
Azure devops is in here because that
must mean they've changed it since I
wrote this demo and it now will create
you a deploy pipeline inside of azure
devops I've not tested this yet so I
might be lying but I can't see why else
they would put it on the screen
we're going to use GitHub and for that
you do get a CI CD pipeline out of the
box
when you create your static web app
so we're going to pick our organization
and it's me
and then we want our
laser talk demo and I want to deploy my
main branch
the thing that we need to do is set our
build presets to tell the CI CD pipeline
how it needs to build the app and for
that we have lots of options available
to us we have angular Blazer next reacts
felt view Gatsby Hugo View Press or even
a custom one so you can put your own
framework in there you're not tied to
Blazer here you can use whatever front
end you want to use
I in the event do want to use Blazer so
I'm going to put that in
and then you get three things that you
need to set up for your application to
build you need to say where your app
location is where your API is your Azure
functions and where your output is going
to be
planes and the API this is why I called
it client and API because then you can
just use it out of the box the less I
have to type the less typos I make
and the output location for Blazer
as far as I can tell it doesn't matter
what you put here for Blazer as long as
it's not a folder which exists in your
repo this will work if you're using
Azure react or view or any JavaScript
content it is a whole other story and
you need to make sure that you get this
absolutely correct the Blazer it's just
really simple
so let's do the review and create
creating a static web app generally
takes about two seconds so this should
be up really quickly or it's going to
make me into a liar
come on you can do it faster than this
there we go
five seconds
and here we have our static web app all
set up and ready to go and over here you
can see we have our URL ambitious Sky
these have the best names
and if we open this up in a new window
we can see yo is your static web app
it's live and it's waiting for your
content
but I've given it my content because
I've given it my GitHub account so where
is it
well if we come back to our GitHub repo
and we refresh the page
we now have a GitHub workflows file in
here
so if we take a very quick look at this
I'm not going to go too in depth but I
just want to show you how it gets out of
your account and into the static web app
we have this static web apps deploy V1
and what that would do it takes a couple
of secrets that the portal creates
inside of your GitHub repo
it builds your client your API and then
it uploads it to the static web app
someone hears there's nothing in here
that says that it's Blazer
so if you switch from Blazer to angular
Jimmy I'm sure that that's something
you're going to be trying
so I'm going to be picking on you a lot
in the next half hour
if you do that you don't actually need
to change anything here aside from these
locations this build step will have a
look at what's in your repo
it will determine what language it's
building
and then it will build and deploy it for
you that goes for the functions as well
that are in API I have used net
functions here but I also have a demo
where I'm using typescript functions and
this is exactly the same it picks it up
on the Fly and the build step takes care
of it for you this is both awesome
and annoying it's awesome because I
don't have to care and it's annoying
because I would like to know a little
bit more about what's going on under the
hood
but it's not there for us
foreign
for every push that we do to main so
we're going to have
this build step here it generally takes
about four minutes to deploy so while
we're waiting for it why don't we try
running it locally and see whether or
not it's going to work in production
so for this one
we kind of have an issue
because we have our client and our API
now I said that in our Azure resource we
have all that wonderful glue in the
middle that turns it into one coherent
application we don't have that locally
one's going to run on one port one's
going to run another port and how do
they talk to each other
during the preview you had to write your
app specifically for this you had to put
steps in there that checked whether or
not you're developing
and then when you went into production
it did something slightly different and
it was it worked well quite well but it
was kind of annoying these days we have
the static web app CLI that we can use
and that replicates that glue inside of
our machine so that's what we're going
to be using today
first thing that we've got to do is make
sure that everything starts so let's set
our startup projects and we want to make
sure that we have both our API
and we want to make sure that we have a
client and we're just going to start
those off
and
it's good we have our Azure always over
here already
and over here we have a web browser
and here's our home and if we go to blog
posts we have the unhandled error that's
because it doesn't know where to find
our API so let's find that API for it
for that one we're going to be using
like say the static web app CLI this is
a node.js server you can install it via
npm and when I say replicate the Azure
function it's really important to
remember it replicates the Azure
resource it doesn't give you a static
web app on your machine 99 of it works
the same as it does in azure but not a
hundred
so always make sure when you do this do
try it in Azure before you push it out
to production because you never know if
you're going to get caught out
but it's perfectly good enough for
building it at home
so we're going to start at our static
web app we're going to go start and all
we're going to tell it is that if it
looks at https
localhost
and we want
7226 if I have read that correctly
yeah
what this is now no that's wrong because
I did not do a colon there
come on stop
cool that really went well didn't it
let's try that one again shall we
cute so we want GitHub we want our
Blazer demo and we want SWA start
https colon slash
localhost
72 2026
. now that I've got the text right what
this is going to do is
any request that it gets on that 4280
that you've just seen appear at the
bottom it's going to push through to My
Demo server so it's just going to push
that food to 72.26 unless that request
is part of the glue inside of the Azure
resource and then it's going to root it
differently anything that goes to API it
is automatically going to root to 7071
because that's the default for Azure
functions if you're running it on a
different port you can override it here
but going through everything that the
static web app CLI does is kind of
literally a different talk
but it works quite well for us so if we
come back to our browser and we go to
localhost
local
host
see this is the reason why I've got so
many Snippets
this is a reason why I generally work
with an external keyboard too
now this is going to take a little bit
longer to look because the CLI does
introduce just a little bit of delay on
that first load as it downloads all of
the wasm stuff all of the.net uh runtime
it is only when you actually load the
page once it's there it is really Snappy
so this looks kind of the same as before
only now if I go to my blog post
we have all of the blog posts that I've
written and if we click on one
it will open up in a new window so she
hopefully
so there we go this this was literally
the first step that I took when I wrote
my own website get this out and after
that started to worry about doing
different things
you can also debug from here so if we
reopen our
Visual Studio
say we come into our blog post page and
we're just going to stick a breakpoint
at the end
and we're going to go into our API and
stick a breakpoint on our blog posts
yeah that's a good one
and then we go back to our page
anybody else have the issue with Visual
Studio 2022 by the way that when you're
in debug mode it's really hard to switch
windows
so when we reload there we go we've gone
through to the API we can now do all of
the debugging that we'd normally do we
can see the request that's coming from
the client and we can work with it as we
want to
and if we go a step further then we can
go into our Blazer coat so even though
we're not using that URL given to us by
the browser all of the debugging still
works for us and I use this for my inner
developer Loop all the time when I'm
working on my site it's it's a really
nice way to work there is one Proviso
that is
I put this URL in the same browser that
Visual Studio opened up and I did that
deliberately
because if I bring this into a different
browser
and I paste it in here even though I've
still got that
breakpoint set
it's going to load it
and I don't hit a breakpoint and that is
because when you're running the web
assembly the browser and visual studio
have some awesome tunneling going on so
that they can speak to each other but
it's only inside of that browser
so what that one caught me out when I
first started doing this and I was
pulling my hair out why does it work
sometimes but not others and it's really
the browser that you choose is whether
or not this works
so that's very quickly how we can debug
now that we have our app loaded our CI
CD flow is finished
we can now come back into our app
we can reload it
you see that's much quicker than it was
on my home machine local machine and we
can now load our blog posts we can open
these
and there we go inside of 20 minutes I
have got my first step live and out to
production
there are problems here
if I refresh my page
I get a wonderful 404 error and I got a
wonderful 404 error because this is a
static site and it is running a Blazer
webassembly application which means this
URL doesn't exist
and so when you refresh it all dies
we're going to solve this one in a
second
the other one that we're going to look
at at the same time is what I was
talking about with wanting to write my
own blog posts in my own site like I say
I want to use my site to practice things
and for that I need to set up
Authentication
now I am not an authentication person I
am really pleased that my company we
have somebody that specializes in that
and I ask their help
started web apps has you covered for
this
you've seen all of the code that I put
in my application but if I come in here
and I go to Dot auth Login slash
Twitter
I know redirect to Twitter I have to
give consent because it wants to use
stuff from my Twitter account
and I am now logged into my application
using my Twitter authentication and that
is all part of the glue that comes with
Azure static web apps nothing's changed
of cooks covered nothing in my app to
take advantage of my authentication but
I can prove to you that there's
something there by going to another URL
inside of that glue
me
and if I look at me then I can see that
I have authenticated let's make that a
bit bigger I've authenticated using
Twitter I have a user ID assigned to me
I am not dodging myself at this point
this user ID is specific to this app so
if you make three Azure static web apps
and you log in with your Twitter account
you will have three different user IDs
they're not comparable between the two
I have my user details which for Twitter
is my handle for GitHub and Twitter it's
your handle if you use Azure active
directory or Google you get your email
address which is why I'm using my
Twitter handle and not my email address
and at the bottom we have our
um user rules that we have available the
anonymous and the authenticated every
single user which logs in on your site
get these roles these are the two
default ones that come out of Microsoft
we can add more we'll come to that later
so let's reset this one
or not
yeah that's okay
so what we're going to do now is add
some basic authentication to the site
well actually we're going to see how to
use the basic authentication in the site
so for this one
we are going to add
a couple of code files in the API a
couple in the client I'm going to
apologize in advance because please do
not build your code like this in real
life but there's like five different
classes and this is quickest way to get
it done when you're trying to do a lot
in just an hour
so let's start our app
and inside of our API we are going to
add a new class
and we're going to call that static web
app API Authentication
and we're going to bring over a whole
load of code
let's start at the bottom because this
is where our models are set up
when I went to auth.me
you saw the setup of the authentication
data that you get from an Azure static
web app and that's what we have here a
client principle with the identity
provider the user ID the user details
the user roles we also have two new ones
here we have an i enumerable of static
web app claims and we have an access
token and the claims are just simply are
two strings type and value
this is for our custom authentication we
don't use these in the standard
Authentication
and then we're going to use that inside
of our app
by
checking out the headers that come to
our API and this particular header that
we're looking at is this one the XMS
client principle your users in their
browsers will never see this header this
is something that the Azure static web
app puts onto the requests as they route
it back to your back end
so we can trust this for our
authentication information
we get it from a Basics to four string
and then we deserialize it into that
client principle and from there we can
work with it
and to turn it into a claims principle
we need to just do a little bit more
processing
first of all I'm stripping off the
anonymous level because honestly I don't
care if somebody's Anonymous if the only
thing they have is anonymous I'm going
to treat them as not logged in which is
exactly what the next couple of lines do
after you've stripped out Anonymous if
you don't have any roles left over we're
just going to return an empty claims
principle that person's not logged in
they're not authenticated we don't know
who they are
if they do have roles left to them then
we create a claims identity based on the
identity provider they're using passing
in either user details and an amount of
roles that they have and from here on in
we can use our claims principle inside
of our app to make sure that when I am
writing blog posts I am writing it under
my name and if I am in a multi-tenant
environment and I'm reading stuff I can
only read the stuff that I have access
to
you can also use this of course to check
that people have access to your apis
but there's a better way of doing that
so I wouldn't do that in the code here
so that's how we do the back end and to
show this working we're just going to
make a couple of extra Azure functions
so we're going to bring in one here
and we're going to call that one
auth test
it's going to be HTTP trigger again
because everything has to be and we're
going to bring in some code
so what we're doing here we have another
HTTP get we're leaving the root empty
here it's just going to be API slash
auth test
we are getting the claims principle back
from the header and then all I'm doing
just to prove that this works is just
dumping an amount of information out to
the screen just so you can see it
happening
and then once that's saved we are going
to copy this one and we're going to use
it again a second time
so where's paste first paste
and we're going to call this one because
naming in it is hard
auth test two
no not all test test or test two
so let's rename our class
we need to do it there we need to do it
here otherwise the functions are going
to complain and we need to do at the
bottom so we get some decent information
out
so now we have two authentication tests
and what we're going to do in a minute
is actually set up the authorization on
the API so that you need different roles
to access these two different apis
we're going to be doing that one in the
front end
and we're going to come to that one in a
second
so in the front end we need to add a
nugget package to our app so let's go
and manage nugget packages and what we
need is the asb.net component
authorization
when you install this make sure you
don't include pre-release because
version 7 is not compatible with version
six and everything dies in a wonderfully
interesting way
foreign
of course in which case do use seven in
the pre-release otherwise you're going
to have different interesting errors
we're going to accept all the licenses
because whoever reads those
and for the front end we're going to
make
again a new class
and
that one is going to be
standard web app authentication client
State provider
in the Sin and again we still have our
client principle the same as we had on
the back end and again in my site this
is all in a separate project that takes
care of all of the authorization but
again that's a little bit too
long-winded for a one-hour demo
and what this one's going to do is
when we get the authentication State
inside of our app we're going to first
of all try and get our client principle
and that client principle it's not
coming from a header this time it's
actually coming from that dot auth me
root that I was talking about and showed
you earlier because this is opening in
the browser when you make a request to
that auth me you get all of your cookies
sent with it and the static web app can
authenticate you so it will give you the
correct information back
then we just do pretty much the same as
we do on the API side we are going to
deserialize that to a client principle
and then we're going to go through
exactly the same process to change that
to a claims principle from this point on
you are just authenticated inside of
your Blazer app and you can use it as
normal
so let's do that
number one we need to add some extra
services to our app
and we need to bring in a couple of
namespaces to get rid of the squiggly
lines so we're going to bring in the
asb.net components authentication and
we're going to bring in
our client auth namespace
now that we have this in place we can
start to make our app do cool stuff with
authentication number one we need to
change our app.razer
at the top here
we're going to bring in a cascading
authentication state
and we're going to close that one as
well otherwise again
bad things happen
and we're going to sort out the tabbing
because again I liked having to be good
now you can notice that we've got a
green squiggly line here and nothing is
in bold and basically our application
does not know how to deal with this
that's because we need to bring in a
using statement
now we can bring this using statement in
here
and that makes it work inside of this
component but I'm going to be using this
in multiple components and I don't want
to add this all the time so actually I'm
going to get rid of this and I'm going
to open the absolutely awesome
underscore imports.razer and I'm going
to bring it in here
because now I've put it in my imports
razor it's available in all of my
components I don't have to think about
this ever again until I open a new app
forget to put it in the import visor and
pull my hair out trying to think why
nothing's working
then we're going to add some navigation
so that our users can log in so again in
our nav menu
we're going to add a new navigation link
and this has this authorized View
and you have a couple of options here
you're either authorized or you are not
authorized
if somebody's authorized we're going to
give them access to a logout screen and
we're also going to give them a special
button if they're a super user because
we want to let our super users know that
they're super users
and if you're not logged in well we're
just going to send you to Twitter to log
in so that everything works
last but not least I said that we can
ensure that our apis also have
authorization on them so that only the
right people can access them and to do
that we're going to create a config.json
now this Json exists in the client even
though it controls the API and it exists
in the client because that is where our
static files live and that is where the
Azure static web apps look to get their
data so inside of our WWE root
we're going to add a new item
and that new item is going to be a Json
file
and we're going to call that
static web app.config.json
now again I can do and I have a whole
talk about what you can do with this
file to control all of the facets of
your static web app we're going to do
just some really small stuff with it
today
we're going to add some roots for our
auth test so if you want to access auth
test you have to be a super user
for our auth test two you just need to
be authenticated anybody who logs in can
use that one
you can also control access to your
pages from here
again that's a slightly different demo
for a slightly different talk but all
I'm going to say is don't and the reason
why I don't is because this only works
inside of the static web app so people
won't be able to deep link to your
counter page they'll get a 404 but if
they're inside of the Blazer app it's a
single page application if they click on
an internal link to that page it's still
going to work so use that authorized
view inside of your app to control the
client side
then we have a
root here now this is pointing to one of
those blue Pages the auth login aad what
this will do is stop people being able
to use Azure active directory to log in
like you saw in my first demo everything
out of the box works we can just go
straight to that Twitter login page and
it's there but you might not want to let
people log in with everything so this
allows you to just put some control over
that and make sure they can only use the
providers that you want them to use
and last but not least we have this
navigation fallback this is going to
stop that problem that we had with
refreshing the page
so when it refreshes now it's going to
redirect to index.html and it's going to
let Blazer take care of all of that
routing for us so that we can get back
to the page where we're on we can do
deep links and email links and ensure
everything works
so one last built did this one this work
did I do it right it succeeded cool
so let's push this up to the front end
again add auth
and we're going to commit and push
come back up to here let's just check
that we do actually have a new CI CD
flow kicked off
and we don't and the reason why we don't
is because I didn't push and pull
I need to push and pull of course
because that workflow file was added to
our GitHub repo so when I tried to push
it went ah not doing that
and I forget this in every single demo
that I do
now we have that running this is good
so like so this is going to take about
another three or so minutes to deploy so
whilst we're waiting for it to deploy
there's just a couple of extra things
that I want to show you to really make
our app look awesome
first one that I want to show you is
custom domains because whilst I think
that the domains that we get from
Microsoft so ambitious sky yellow Rock
scary C it sounds awesome but it's not
my brand and I'm supposed to be doing
this to build my brand on top of that I
really don't want to tell people that
you have to go to ambitious sky oea480f
03.1 in order to get to my website I
want you to go to the actual place
thankfully that is also really easy to
set up inside of a static web app I am
not doing this in the one I just created
because you have to do stuff with your
DNS provider in order to get this work
that can work in seconds and it can work
in two days and I don't think you want
to sit here for the next two days
waiting for that bit to work
so I have this second one that I've set
up and we are going to add an extra
domain to this one so that we can access
it on my personal we're going to do
stacyclouds.com
important thing here this is where you
get into the differences between that
free tier and the standard tier for the
free tier you can have two custom
domains on your static web app and
that's really useful because if you want
to do
www.stacey clouds.com and
stacyclouds.com you need two custom
domains in order to get that to work
on the paid version you get five
so that I don't know I don't know why
you want to use five but you get five
so we're going to add a new custom
domain here and that's going to be
www.stacy hey look at that it's already
got it
stacyclouds.com and then it's going to
tell us what we need to do to our DNS to
get this to work we need to make a cname
on the www level of our DNS records and
it has to point to our application
then we click add and if I pick the
right domain name this is now going to
sit and it's going to sit in the
background and whirl away and do lots of
interesting stuff for the coming five
minutes and hopefully by the time I
reach the end of the talk I'm going to
be able to go tada
otherwise I'm going to go trust me it
works
let's see which one we get to
how we're doing before I deploy come on
I would have thought you'd have been
deployed by now
where are we two minutes 32 it's about
another minute left to go
so I'm going to jump forward just a
little bit
the other thing that we can have inside
of our app
um oh come on what do you mean I can't
step away from this page
we'll do this a different way the other
thing that we want to do is to be able
is to push things to a production-like
environment before we actually go to
production remember me saying that the
static web app
isn't really a static web app and it
does have a couple of small differences
between what you get locally and what
you get in production
well there's an easy way to do that
thankfully
if we go back to our workflow file
it's in here somewhere
not only do you have the build job we
also have this pull request job and what
that will do is do all of the normal
steps that we have before
and it will spin up a staging
environment for you so that you can test
things in that production-like
environment before you actually push
them to production
and I'm in the UK I don't know how old
the people in the audience are but in
great blue Peter terms here's one I made
earlier
inside of our pull request
we get a deploy for us and we can click
on this and come out
and assuming Azure does its thing we
have an application
now what I want to show you is this
fetch data because I originally wrote
this demo in the middle of winter so oh
the weather outside is frightful and
that's the last icing
originally it said something different
so let's compare it to the original if I
can do this right
the way that it builds up the URL you
can see that we have this West Europe
and we have this one that is a change
that it adds to your staging account
what that means is whilst your general
static web apps are available around the
world
your staging apps are hosted in a
particular region so obviously they're
still available everywhere but they
aren't actually stored in a certain
place
now have I deleted the right things I've
not deleted the right things
okay but that's close so we can come to
here
so inside of this oh that's interesting
I can't show you it completely
we see the URLs actually changed to
stacyclouds.com now if we open this
please trust me this is the same one
oh come on
okay Microsoft Azure has done something
slightly interesting here please trust
me this does generally work
I'm guessing the um the certificate
isn't quite correct set up yet that
generally sorts itself out after a few
minutes and of course not in the middle
of a demo
so please just trust me you're gonna
have to trust me on this one
you set up your staging account you can
check that it works as it does you can
check the differences of what they need
to be and then when you complete your
pull request it even cleans up after
itself so your staging environments
disappear as you close your pull
requests your work in progress is also
kind of force tip because you only have
a limited number of staging slots that
you can use
these are by default open to the world
so if you're deploying something that
people shouldn't look at you need to go
into the configuration and turn that off
you can put it behind a password
that's a relatively new thing when they
first came out or Microsoft said was
these are open to the world and if you
don't want them to be don't use the
staging slots turn that off in your
pipeline
at least we're one step further along
now
so how are we doing for our actions okay
the action's finished now which means if
we come in here and reboot
we should now be able to log in now I'm
already logged in as Twitter so we can
see that I'm a standard user here
and if I try and go to API slash
auth test
we should get a 403 Forbidden error so
that comes from that static web app uh
config that I was showing you
on the other hand
we go to test two
we actually see that that function went
and we can see it so again without us
actually having to put that
authorization onto the apis it exists
for us and again code I don't have to
write it's code that I can't introduce
books to
so there's one last thing that I want to
show you and that is adding roles to our
application because I want to actually
get to see that authentication test URL
this one
so what I'm going to do is log out of
here
I'm going to come back and come to role
management inside of the static web app
this is another one where that
difference between the standard tier and
the free tier matters on the free tier
you can only add 25 records here that is
not to say you can only have 25 users
but you can only have 25 users with
special roles for many apps that's going
to be enough if it's not enough you can
take the standard tier and then in this
page you can do 25 different roles which
sounds kind of similar and I don't know
why Microsoft's done that
what you can do if you've got custom
authentication in the standards here is
you can write in Azure function to
provide the roles you get a request from
the static web app you get the access
token from your user you get a load of
extra information and you can Define
your roles at that point and then it is
unlimited
what we're going to do here is just
invite somebody in
and we're going to use GitHub here and
it's going to be Stacy cash because it's
going to be me and we're going to give
Stacy cash
super super super super
user rights
so we're going to generate a link we're
going to copy this
and we're going to bring it in here
now again I'm going to have to consent
to this because I've never used it
before and now I am a super user so I
should now have access to that API so
let's do a quick check before we finish
or where's all test slash or test
and there we go
that is how quick and easy it is to get
a role set up an extra Proviso here it
is this quick and easy to set up but it
is also cached inside of your study web
app so if you need to change this it's
going to take about 25 minutes before it
takes effect and that does include
deleting people from your application
you don't have instant control if you do
it via the um the rules page
and looking at the time we're about out
which is not bad timing
so
we had a few interesting bits in there
I'm sorry not everything worked but in
about 50 minutes or so we have created a
website we've created the API we've
deployed it up to Azure into a
production environment not production
like our production environment we've
set up a CI CD pipeline we have checked
how we can debug locally we've also
checked how to make sure that things
going into production actually do what
they're supposed to do in production and
we have had a quick look at the standard
level of authentication so that you can
check that the users using your app are
the users that are supposed to using
your be using your app
I hope that you found this interesting
and inspiring there's a QR code on the
page that will take you to the MS learn
documentation so that you can try this
for yourself
if you're not inspired to try it
yourself go there anyway because
seriously Ms learn is so full of awesome
information it's just a URL that you
should be checking out
thank you so much for your time today
I'm happy that I didn't fall over the
Gap behind the stage which I was worried
about before I started
I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference thanks